[Música]
en junio del 2010 tenía un trabajo que
disfrutaba mucho en ese momento estaba
haciendo amistades nuevas y me la pasaba
muy agusto con ellos estaba a punto de
terminar mi carrera sin embargo había
algo que no me hacía sentir totalmente
satisfecha y era que cada noche al verme
sentía mucha impotencia y mucha
frustración porque una vez más había
pasado el día sin poder lograr lo que
siempre había querido bajar de peso
en ese momento en las noches muchas
ocasiones llorando me preguntaba estoy
destinada a esto esto tendrá que ser así
siempre toda mi vida
al día siguiente me proponía empezar de
nuevo algunas de las muchas cosas que
había hecho anteriormente ir al
nutriólogo a las agujas intentar hacer
ejercicios licuados y empezaba muy
emocionada a las 11 de la mañana se me
olvidaba se me olvidaba que una noche
antes me había propuesto esto
y decía si es algo que deseo con todo mi
corazón porque parece que ser que es lo
último que quiero lograr por supuesto
que esto lo vivía en silencio según yo
era la única persona que estaba viviendo
lo que yo vivía
me enteré que había una persona en un
lugar internada para bajar de peso y que
llevaba 40 kilos menos en ese momento
dije lo que sea yo me voy a ir y yo voy
a hacer lo que ella está haciendo hable
para pedir información me dijeron ya te
puedes venir en menos de 10 días había
dejado todo dejé mi trabajo la escuela
mis amigos y me fui
cuando iba camino al lugar
me dicen
me imaginaba caminando entre las
caballerizas me imaginaba corriendo en
una milla una de las cosas que me
preguntaron cuando hable me dicen cuánto
pesas pensé en decir que menos pero a
eso iba no tenía caso 130 dije esta soy
yo
en ese momento cuando llegue al lugar yo
no sabía cómo se llamaba lo primero que
veo es que dice dragones anónimos
sentí mucho coraje y mucho enojo de de
ver cómo había permitido que mi vida
llegar a ese punto
inicié mi proceso al día siguiente me
dicen el regalo más pequeño que vas a
recibir en este lugar es bajar de peso
en comparación con todo lo demás para mí
no era así para mí lo más importante era
bajar de peso a mí no me importaba todos
los beneficios que podía recibir a
través de esto
mucho tiempo había soñado con que eso
existiera con que pudiera encerrarme en
un lugar en donde solamente me dieron la
comida que necesitaba comer para poder
lograr bajar de peso
empecé mi proceso al escuchar a mis
compañeras hablar de cómo vivían ellos
en relación a la comida no tardé mucho
en decir están locas yo no vivo lo que
ellas viven había personas que sacaban
comida de la basura y comían había
personas que en su cuerpo escondían
comida caliente yo no hacía eso pero si
mentía en relación a la comida si decía
que no había cenado cuando ya lo había
hecho muchas veces iba a la tienda y me
hacía tonta con el teléfono diciendo
quieres que te lleve unas papitas unas
galletas una soda según yo para que el
señor de la tienda no dijera te vas a
comer todo eso
muchas veces compraba varias bolsas de
sabritas y las echaba en una sola bolsa
para que la gente no viera que no me
conformaba con una bolsa
a pesar de todo esto de verdad yo creía
que podía manejar la situación en el
momento en que yo quisiera pero no me lo
había propuesto refrán de todo adicto al
fin de cuentas había intentado mil veces
anteriormente hacer algo sin poder
lograrlo
me impresionaba mucho cuando
acompañábamos a alcohólicos anónimos a
ciertas reuniones ver la similitud que
había entre ellos y nosotros
ellos también mentían también escondían
la bebida el alcohol yo también lo hacía
a ellos el alcohol los hacía sentir bien
a mí un chocolate me hacía feliz ellos
pensaban y decían que podían dejar de
beber cuando quisieran yo también lo
hacía y ni ellos ni yo lográbamos hacer
algo con esto
cada semana veía los resultados de la
pérdida de peso y eso era lo que me
mantenía motivada estaba bajando de peso
pero no estaba aprendiendo los primeros
seis meses se me fueron de noche me
costaba mucho trabajo obedecer las
reglas me costaba mucho trabajo entender
que tenía que comer es decir ese tipo de
alimentos cuestionaba todo lo que se
hacía en ese lugar
un día llegó soy de una compañera de
aquí hermosillo a vivir también su
internamiento a diferencia de mí ella sí
sabía que su pérdida de peso tenía algo
que ver con su con la forma con la parte
emocional ella sí sabía que no solamente
era el peso fue en ese momento que me
interesé por conocer más por aprender de
qué se trataba el programa disfrutaba
mucho platicar con las personas que
estaban viviendo lo mismo que yo
en ese lugar me obligaban y digo me
obligaban porque yo no quería a trabajar
en mi historia a revisar qué es lo que
me estaba llevando a tener una mala
relación con la comida me decían que en
mi historia había mucha información
fue entonces que poco a poco empecé a
descubrir y empecé a recordar que de
niña había dos cosas que me habían
marcado una yo no tenía papá y mis dos
primas y tenían papá y dos
yo tenía sobrepeso y ellas no lo tenían
fue entonces que dije bueno pues por
aquí debe de ser algo debo de trabajar
realmente entendí que había utilizado la
comida como anestesia que no quería
sentir y que la comida el mejor trabajo
descubrí que mi relación con la comida
no es sana y que no es como las demás
personas se relacionan con ella
me di cuenta que había alimentos que
daban mi ansiedad y mi compulsión que
había alimentos con los que no podía
tener contacto igual que una persona
alcohólica
a lo largo del proceso entendí que mi
compulsión no procedía de malos hábitos
adquiridos en la infancia ni procedía de
de problemas de adaptación sabía que era
más allá ni siquiera procedía del gusto
por la comida
entendí que yo no sabía cómo enfrentarme
a la vida si no tenía la comida y sabía
cómo manejar la tristeza no sabía cómo
manejar el enojo y mejor comía no sabía
cómo manejar la soledad y mejor comía
incluso no sabía cómo manejar la
felicidad porque también por eso comía
aunque parezca exagerado la comida
siempre ha estado ahí siempre me estuvo
acompañando la comida se convirtió en mi
mejor amiga no me juzgaban
llegó el momento de regresar hermosillo
con 50 kilos menos llego y empiezo a
descubrir que no sabía cómo relacionarme
nuevamente y no me habían enseñado en
este proceso a convivir con un nuevo
peso
empecé a buscar ayuda toqué puertas
porque no quería perder lo que había
ganado en ese lugar no había muchas
opciones fue entonces que descubrí que
quizá mi propósito de vida era dedicarme
a esto a poder acompañar y que mi
historia sirva para que otras personas
aprendan lo que yo también aprendí
en el año 2013 en enero decidimos
iniciar un proyecto abrir institutos ver
una escuela para personas con obesidad y
con sobrepeso invitamos a sus y una
compañera de aguascalientes a que
viviera la misma experiencia que
habíamos vivido nosotros que dejará todo
hiciera un alto en su vida y ser y se
viniera para acá a vivir un
internamiento y que viviera la
experiencia de enfocarse 100% en esto en
dos meses ya lo teníamos en hermosillo
fue entonces que decidimos acelerar el
proceso y en los seis meses después
abrimos la casita le decíamos era una
casa pequeña donde compartíamos espacios
donde vivíamos el internamiento
empezamos hoy de susana yo y dos amigos
más a los seis meses pues que
inauguramos instituto al sur
y porque haysbert
estamos convencidas que si entendemos la
filosofía del ice bird damos un gran
paso en este proceso si nosotros vemos
la parte de arriba es lo que se alcanza
a ver a simple vista esto representa el
peso y la forma de comer pero también
representa la parte más pequeña del
problema es necesario ir abajo y voltear
a ver lo que no se ve que representa la
parte emocional y la parte espiritual
a través de nutriólogos de dietas de
ejercicio podemos trabajar la parte de
arriba y es cuando empezamos a raspar
esa parte pero si no trabajo lo que está
originando el sobrepeso solamente
estamos trabajando a medias con los
métodos convencionales
hoy en día la cirugía bariátrica es una
herramienta útil para personas con
obesidad mórbida hoy se vende como una
solución no lo es es sólo una
herramienta que trabaja la parte física
porque es importante sumar la parte
emocional la parte espiritual
marian williamson lo dice muy claro
cuando los kilos desaparecen del cuerpo
pero no del alma
simplemente se recicla en apariencia
pero acaban por volver
es aquí donde la enfermedad de la
adicción empieza porque se origina abajo
se origina en la parte emocional
you dijo liz en su libro lo decía es un
problema familiar dice cuando uno no
tiene la sustancia se siente mal cuando
la tiene no se siente bien qué quiere
decir que a pesar de que mi forma de
comer sea compulsiva y en ese momento
pueda anestesiar un poco lo que estoy
sintiendo en este momento pueda sentirme
mejor sin lugar a dudas no está
trabajando a raíz el problema sigue
estando ahí el miedo sigue estando ahí
y
vemos que la incapacidad de la persona
el pensamiento de activo dice que que la
incapacidad de la persona de tomar
decisiones sanas para nuestro propio
bien en mi caso yo sabía que estaba
deformando mi cuerpo el cuello se
empezaba a oscurecer por la resistencia
a la insulina y aún así no podía hacer
nada por mí como no entender que
realmente va más allá de poder razonar
para mi propio bien
vemos diferentes etapas en la obesidad
primero tenemos que aceptarlo y una de
las primeras etapas es la negación aquí
no hay conciencia enfermedad no me doy
cuenta y no quiero ver que tengo un
problema
no estoy gorda no como tanto no lo veo
esta era mi realidad este de la realidad
yo solamente veía esa parte yo tomé la
primera foto la otra la tomo a alguien
más yo solamente veía cuando vi la otra
foto dije no soy yo si eran
después viene la rebeldía hay un cierto
reconocimiento del problema porque la
gente me lo hace saber
deberías bajar de peso estás muy gorda
sin embargo ahí se hace que tengo algo
que hacer
aquí le echamos la culpa a los demás en
mi caso yo siempre le eché la culpa a mi
mamá porque ella era gorda y porque
nunca me había enseñado a comer sano
viene la racionalización aquí yo busco
la manera de justificar seguir comiendo
está la negociación acepto que necesito
ayuda pero a mi manera
acepto que que si necesito que me digan
que hacer pero yo cambio las cosas
muchas veces me tocó ir a las agujas en
cuanto salía del consultorio lo primero
que hacía era quitarme las porque no
quería que la gente lo viera me daba
vergüenza pero veía en mi cuerpo
bien en la percepción del tiempo un
adicto ha transitado el camino de la
gratificación inmediata quiero lo que
quiero y lo quiero ya la comida da ese
placer la comida lo da en el momento
tenemos la ilusión que cuando logra
bajar de peso voy a volver a comer de
una forma como lo hacía antes
una vez internada me tocó la experiencia
donde nos dice una persona no pues es
que picar la fruta muy chiquita para que
quepa más cantidad en el vaso no creo
que yo le dije en la si deja no lo vas a
poder comer todo lo que tú quieras es a
esta parte donde tenemos la ilusión de
que cuando resolución a esta parte en mi
vida volverá a ser como antes
y aquí viene el ciclo adictivo cualquier
relación adictiva surge porque hay algo
que no quiero sentir hay algo que no
quiero ver entonces aparece un dolor
después viene la necesidad de comer
compulsivamente para no sentir ese dolor
después viene el comer compulsivamente
pues me da una satisfacción y después
esa misma satisfacción me da otra vez el
dolor y así es el ciclo de la adicción
viene la aceptación en esta etapa acepto
que hay algo que tengo que trabajar y
que esto es para toda la vida ya no
cuestiono si después me voy a curar si
no se convierte en un estilo de vida
también viene la recaída la recaída
es un proceso es una parte importante de
la recuperación la recaída es parte del
proceso y me viene a recordar que hay
algo que necesito seguir trabajando me
viene a recordar que hay algo que
necesito voltear a ver
es impresionante las cifras que tenemos
en méxico ocupamos el lugar número uno
en obesidad infantil y el número dos en
obesidad en adultos y para el 2050 se
prevé que el 88 por ciento de los
hombres y el 91 por ciento de las
mujeres tengan sobrepeso
tenemos que hacer algo tenemos que
reconocer que este es que esta es una
enfermedad que necesita ser reconocida
como tal que necesita medidas estrictas
para poder solucionarlo
en este momento yo les quisiera decir al
gobierno hay mucho que hacer en este
tema hay países que no son el número uno
en obesidad y no se encuentran en los
primeros lugares y los programas que
tienen de prevención han sido muy
exitosos como en españa' en chile donde
trabajan de forma integral trabajan con
niños docentes sociedad y padres de
familia
es urgente hacer algo a la sociedad yo
les quisiera decir la adicción va más
allá de la fuerza de voluntad la
adicción no tiene nada que ver con que
échale ganas
dejemos de decirle eso las personas deja
de comer esto comen menos soda con menos
tortilla si alguien tiene fuerza de
voluntad somos nosotros porque no hemos
quitado el dedo del renglón y lo hemos
intentado una y otra y otra vez sin
embargo no se trata de fuerza de
voluntad
hoy en día la bulimia y la anorexia es
reconocida como tal y en las personas
que la padecen se les trata así como una
enfermedad sin embargo a la persona
gorda obesa se le clasifica como el
perezoso el flojo que no hace algo por
ellos
a las familias que están preocupadas
porque tienen algún ser querido con este
problema dejen de hacer las mismas cosas
esperando resultados diferentes busquen
algún profesional alguien que los
atienda de forma integral alrededor de
una persona con obesidad hay 15
codependientes a un lado la obesidad es
un problema familiar y a veces el
familiar es el que más ayuda necesita
a los profesionales nutriólogos
terapeutas psicólogos médicos en general
infórmese sobre este tema exploren
nuevas perspectivas no es un problema de
la fuerza de voluntad esto viene del ser
y no del hacer
y a las personas que viven este problema
yo les digo no son culpables ustedes no
lo causaron las personas que viven este
problema hay solución ahí hay una
comunidad que te puede ayudar
dice el libro alcohólicos anónimos o
rara vez hemos visto fracasar a alguien
a una persona que sigue concienzudamente
nuestro camino y una de las promesas que
tiene el programa de alcohólicos
anónimos es veremos resultados antes de
llegar a la mitad del camino no tengan
duda que en comunidad se puede lograr lo
que solos no hemos podido hacer muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]